UNDERWAY WITH LINDHOLM FIRING I
WERE PEL1-0 LEAD WITH
JUST THREE SECONDS LEFT ON THE
POWER  KNOWSLY
WHERE THE STICK OFIN.
SMITH WONDERING HOW THAT ONE GOT
BY HIM,  ON
THE STICK OF MILANO, WHO JUST
GETS THE PADDLE DOWN.
JUST A PER POWER PLAY GOAL!
OILERS ON THE BOARD!PASS ACROSSO
WHAT A TIP BY DEREK RYAN!
AND THIS
MORE OFTEN THAN NOT, DEREK RYAN
SHOWING HAND EYE COORDINATION IN
THE HIGH SLOT, HE'S TIPPED AMCD
DOES HAVE ITS FIRST LEAD!'S IN !
THAT'S FOUR UNANSWERED, AND DIS
PASSES LIKE  DESPERATELY. YEARL,
WHEN TRAILING AFTER TWO, AND
SMITH,SCORES!
FOEGELE, AND THAT LINE HOME, WA
FOEGELE SLIDES OUT, HE'S WIDE
OPEN,IT,  BANKED IT
IN OFF MIKE SMITH, AND ZEGRAS,
IN ONE FELL SWOOP, PUTTING HIS
SKILL ONO
BITE, DROPPED DOWN, THERE IS A
REBOUND IN FRONT, DRAISAITL SCO!
PICKS IT OFF AGAINST LINDHOLM,
GETS HIMSELF INTO POSITIONING,
LISTEN SLOT, WHICH
IS A DANGEROUS POSITION TO BE
IN, GOES TO THE BACK HAND, AND